[Music]
hello everyone
uh so in the previous part of the
lecture we were discussing about
the connection between the vector
representations
in two different coordinate axes
what we are going to do in this part of
the lecture is to
establish a similar sort of connection
between a tensor of order two now before
we can do that
let us quickly recap what we had done
for the tensor of order one that is a
vector in the previous part
so if we go back to the previous page we
see
that this relation vj dash is equal to
qjk
vk is where we had this connection
and you see that the way it was
structured
the index notation it came out was that
this index
j it was present in the first index on
the right hand side here
okay so in general if we
write like a v i
dash it should come out as q
i uh
t v p so where i have deliberately used
a different letter for this index i use
p
instead of j just to emphasize that this
is indeed a dummy index
now if we have to obtain a similar sort
of relation
or a second order tensor then does it
mean that we have to again go through
the laborious process that we had done
in the previous part of the lecture
the answer is no what we can do instead
is to think
of a second order tensor like this
this t i j dash where the dash
represents that the representation is
taking place with respect to the x 1
dash x 2 dash and x 3 dash
axis that that reference system
[Music]
we can think of this to be
made up of the direct product between
two vectors so a i
b j so a i dash b j dash so
these are individually two vectors the
direct product between them
that results in this eij dash so this
this this is something which you have
already seen earlier that the direct
product of two vectors gives rise to a
tensor
okay now uh the moment we have this kind
of a decomposition
what we can do is we can immediately
utilize
this relation which we have already
obtained earlier
to write these individual vectors in
terms
of their uh
in terms of their vector representations
in the x 1 x 2 x 3 axis
so this one will be q i
uh let's put a p here
so this will be a p and for the pj dash
let us use another letter for the second
index
so this is q j
q b
q all right so
let us take the q's to one side
u i p q j q
and the a b and the b q they are
together
now this particular combination a p b q
that will be nothing but
the second order tensor itself in the x
1 x 2 x
x 3 coordinate axis so
this will be yes t p q
so you see with these very simple steps
we have basically obtained the
connection that we desired
so this is the the the representation of
the second order tensor
in the x one x and the x one dash x two
dash x three
dash uh coordinate axis and here
is the second order tensor
representation
in the x1 x2 x3 axis and the connection
is through this this
q1 qip and the qjq
and please note the difference with the
the connection
in the case of the vector representation
so here we had
the presence of only one q term and here
we have the presence of
two q terms okay now uh
you see how this has shaped up we have
the presence of this i
index and the j index on the left hand
side these i's
this i and this j are present separately
here
in the first index of the q here q i
p and here q j q so i comes in the first
index here j comes in the first index
here
and the the second indices here the p
and the q they are how the connection is
made with the
the second order tensor in the other
coordinate axis
now in a similar fashion we can quickly
write down
that suppose we have a third order
tensor
okay so suppose we have something like
this
a i j k dash
without writing any more thing we can
quickly write it down
as q i p
uh q
j q q
k r
a t
u r where this a
eq r is the third order is the
representation of the third order tensor
in the x1 x2 x3 axis
and these are the connections that we
have okay
so this is a very very useful thing to
have and
you can we can actually continue doing
this thing uh
for fourth order tensors and higher
order tensors
and this is something uh which we should
keep in mind
because it will be useful to solve some
problems uh in the subsequent chapters
also
all right so with this we have uh
more or less covered uh what we needed
in the mathematical preliminaries
so as and when required uh we will need
to
refer to these contents uh
and there will be lot of lots of such
occasions uh
and in the next chapter we'll
begin our studies of
the next chapter will be on kinematics
and
the and the subsequent chapter will be
on stress
uh and in both these chapters you will
see that
there will be heavy use of this this
mathematical preliminary concepts
all right thank you very much